this is one of our clinical rooms we
have identified this room as a isolation
room they're getting ready just in case
sexual health clinics like this one will
be crucial in detecting monkey pox
should anyone come through into clinic
that requires a skin check we have
identified an isolation room our staff
are all being tested for their masks and
wearing complete ppe so we would keep my
staff safe and other members of the
public safe that come in
i will need you to stand up the virus
spreads through close contact so staff
here need to be protected
even though monkey pox can present as an
sti it's not a sexually transmitted
infection anyone can catch and pass on
the virus but here in england the
majority of the cases that have been
identified are among the gay and
bisexual community and among men who
have sex with men
again
there's a danger of stigmatizing this
community but health officials have
credited them with the early detection
of infections
we've been trained it's instilled into
us now that sexual health how to look
after our own sexual health
stephen hart is using his social media
channels and his radio show to address
rising anxiety
it's about making sure people know that
it's not a
virus that's only gonna you know
get big game bisexual men it's just
that's what's happened so far monkey pox
was first detected in the 1970s
outbreaks outside africa
are still rare
this is the scar that i received from
monkey pox in 2003.
around 20 years ago veterinary surgeon
kurt zaysky caught the infection from
rats imported from west africa into the
united states i was feeling like i had a
very bad bout of the flu it was only
that one blister on my thumb that was
quite uncomfortable
i ended up having to go back into
urgent care to have that excised and
biopsy
the government like this clinic hopes
the outbreak can be contained
but it needs to make sure
it is prepared ashish joshi sky news